哟,我来了,欢迎来到投机实验室
前些天,国外发生了一件大事
在交易市场上赚到过1500万美元的男人
欧马尔·阿什拉夫
诚实地透露了他作为超短线交易员
获得高额收益的关键细节
和经常能使他盈利的交易系统
研究了三遍他所有的内容之后
我得出一个结论
这就是日内交易的真相
这些经验在过去帮他赚了很多钱
相信之后也会对各位的钱包产生很大的帮助
这期节目值得所有交易员反复观看
现在检查一下是否点击了订阅按钮
以免错过更加有利可图的交易内容
乌马尔交易的流程非常固定
一般分为五个步骤
我们完全可以复制过来作为挤用
第一个步骤是交易前的准备
首先我们应该有一个具体且现实的目标
乌马尔发现包括他在内的很多交易员
总喜欢有一些不切实际的想法
比如你自己本来只有一千美金
年底目标却是账户翻到一千万
比如你每笔交易的止损
只想付出一优
却每次都设置一千优的止盈幅度
再比如你总是喜欢买容易归零的山寨币种
却幻想价值投资到第二个比特币
等等这些都是很不切合实际的目标和想法
它们会影响到你每一笔交易
让你做出非常离谱的交易决策
正确的方式是应该定一个切实可行的目标
比如通过优化交易策略提高胜率
或者改善每笔交易风险回报的比例再或者能像退学炒股一样在交易初期就能靠交易的利润维持生活开销这些实际的目标才能真正的帮你保持正确的交易心态
对你日常交易中的操作产生正面影响
有了一个阶段的目标后
每天交易前的例行程序
就是培养纪律和实现目标的第一步
这可以帮助我们定下每个交易日整天的基调
以正确的心态去应对市场
有些人喜欢以晨跑开始新的一天
还有些人喜欢花时间看看经济数据或者新闻消息等等
这完全取决于你自己的习惯
有规律的生活能减少市场波动对我们情绪的影响
稳定的交易历程能让交易的心态也变得稳定
第二个步骤是交易开始前最好要发个誓言
相当于销售人员每天早上给自己打鸡血抽耳光一样
这是一种备受争议
但是却很有效的给自己洗脑的做法
誓言本质上是一种加强对目标和计划执行承诺的一种方式
可以提醒你
这一天都不能偏离交易计划
时间久了
你就会对止盈值损越来越坚定
现在就把你的读试写下来
放在你随时能看到的地方
前两个步骤都与情绪相关
人们不能消除自己的情绪
但可以管理它
能否长期实现盈利
心理因素可能会占了90%
第三个步骤是设定清晰的交易计划
并坚决执行
Omar说
作为一名合格的交易员
不应该去预测行情
他的任务是根据价格的行为
做出反应
很明显
他是一位价格行为交易员分析过他全部的交易视频后发现他经常选择在关键区域进行突破或者波段操作也就是在支撑阻力位和供给需求区域附近交易
他会提前分析出大级别周期的关键位置
并在图表中标注出来
然后在开始交易之前
观察价格在哪个区间内波动
当价格接近他设定的关键区域时准备交易
交易前会计划好
在什么时机进场
在哪里设置止损不仅不容易被打到
还能在走势不如预期时限制损失
指引的位置设在哪里
大概率会成交
有没有增长的空间
防止提早获利了结
价格反转后又该如何操作等等
有这样一个交易计划的剧本
是非常有必要的
以这笔亚马逊的空单为例
乌马尔在一分钟图表
观察到价格从127
反弹到了130附近的大周期供应区位置
并没有放量突破的迹象
他认为现在价格已经上涨疲软
于是准备在供应区附近设置空单
如果价格突破130.5
它就会止损
只应设置在下方的顶底转换结构位
也就是128.8附近
可以看到
这笔订单的走势如预期下跌
当价格到达128.8附近的只盈位后出场
有人会说
如果不只盈后面的盈利空间更大
但是欧马从来只吃确定性高的一段走势
这也是他能稳定盈利的关键
他是超短线高杠杆选手
贪婪和恐惧都是他必须要克服的
第四个步骤是设置仓位的规模与风险的范围这个步骤非常重要同样盈利百万美元的交易员拜恩斯也这样认为他说自己每笔交易的风险是1000美元从来也不会把它提高或降低
虽然他的净资产已经达到了数百万
有很多人会问他
为什么不提高仓位或扩大风险回报比
他说他绝对不会犯这样的错误
冒着1000美元的风险去赚2000美元
就不会因为亏损而感到不安
这些亏损额度不会触动他的情绪
这是他保持交易状态很重要的一点
他的建议是
当你选择一个
你不会在意的仓位规模与风险范围时
你的交易状态才是最好的
第五个步骤是记录和复盘交易
持续的优化改进交易方式
可以帮助自己稳步提高交易水平
这个过程比较繁琐
需要经常复盘图表
和分析自己以往做过的交易
乌马尔赚到的1500万美元
其中绝大部分来自于近几年
前期的盈利可能只能占到10%到20%
交易是一个长期的过程
以交易为生需要学习的东西很多
退神说过
有的人交易之余喜欢打发时间
有的人却在利用这段时间不断提高
人与人的差距就是这样慢慢加大的
有人十多年的交易经验
可能都不及别人两年的水平
尽管各种经济金融交易知识很枯燥
尽管记录每笔交易
复盘市场走势很辛苦
你要去思考与时俱进
要去求教指点迷津
才能从其他交易员的钱包里
拿走利润
好了
记得点赞收藏
再检查一下订阅按钮
祝你早安晚晚
拜拜